Chers colocataires, comme on va vivre ensemble,
pour la bonne entente de la coloc, on a décidé avec ma cousine Shirley que ce soir,
on allait faire un jeu.
Qu'est-ce qui est court et qui se jette ?
Une courgette.
Quel plat sent le cul de vache ?
La langue de bœuf, pour ceux qui ne le savait pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'un lampadaire ?
Une lampe avec une bosse.
Comment appelle-t-on les parents de l'Homme Invisible ?
Les transparents.
Melon et Melèche veulent ouvrir une boulangerie,
Melon fait les baguettes, et Melèche les miches.
Ça là, c'est un rire Duchenne, un authentique rire Duchenne.
Est-ce que tu veux qu'on te réexplique les règles de ton propre jeu ?
JSAIS PAS SI VOUS AVEZ REMARQUÉ mais on a tous plusieurs façons de rire.
Comme les scientifiques A-DO-RENT ranger les choses.
C'est leur côté Marie Kondo.
ils ont rangé ces rires en plusieurs catégories.
D’abord, le rire authentique et spontané
(comme moi)
qu’on appelle le rire Duchenne, et ensuite… tout le reste.
Bien, merci les mecs.
Non en vrai c’est parce que ces deux types de rires n’empruntent pas les mêmes circuits dans le cerveau.
Parmi les rires jugés non “authentiques”,
il y a le rire conversationnel qui ponctue nos fins de phrases,
le rire gêné (celui que vous avez quand j’essaye d’être drôle, comme maintenant),
le rire poli, le rire nerveux, le rire moqueur, bref tout ça c’est ce qu’on appelle le rire non Duchenne.
Du médecin français Guillaume Duchenne de Boulogne.
Très grand clinicien du XIXème siècle et fondateur de la neurologie.
Rien que ça.
Son truc à lui, c’était de s’amuser avec l’électricité pour voir comment les muscles du corps humain réagissent.
C’est comme ça qu’il a décrit diverses expressions faciales,
en électrifiant notamment le visage d’un patient paralysé.
Dans le lot, y’avait bien évidemment le sourire et le rire “vrai”.
Et voilà comment se manifeste ce fameux rire Duchenne.
Monté, tu serais dispo pour un truc là, c'est pour la science.
J'espère que ça vaut le coup parce que j'ai des trucs à faire, donc, vas-y.
Le rire Duchenne, l’authentique, nécessite l’action conjuguée d’au moins 15 muscles faciaux.
Notamment, les zygomatiques : les coins de la bouche reculent et remontent.
On contracte aussi les muscles des yeux, les orbicularis oculi.
En conséquence, les pommettes remontent et les yeux se plissent.
Et c’est précisément grâce à ces muscles des yeux qu’on arrive à distinguer le vrai rire du rire forcé,
et le vrai du faux sourire.
Bah, fais un effort.
Je fais un effort, je suis heureux, ça se voit pas Valentine ?
Vient ensuite le rire à proprement parler.
C’est une expiration soudaine suivie de cycles d’inspiration/expiration saccadés.
Contrairement à la respiration normale, on expulse l’air de ses poumons de manière active en contractant ses abdos,
en sollicitant son diaphragme et sa cage thoracique.
C'est du sport !
Pendant l’expiration on peut émettre des interjections primaires comme…
Ha ha ha ha.
Ho ho ho ho.
Hi hi hi hi.
Typiquement, 4 à la suite avec une intensité décroissante au fur et à mesure qu’on expire parce qu’on a de moins en moins d’air dans les poumons.
Chaque “ha” dure à peu près 75 millisecondes et il est séparé du suivant par un silence de 210 millisecondes.
C’est très précis, c’est la science.
Le rire peut être extrêmement différent d’une personne à une autre.
Même si, en moyenne, le rire d’une femme aura une fréquence fondamentale de 502 Hz comme ceci :
[rire de femme]
et le celui d’un homme est plutôt aux alentours de 276 Hz
[rire masculin]
Et en général, on a un rire plus aigu quand on se fait chatouiller.
Mais malgré ces variations dans la forme, le rire est universel chez l'humain.
L’historien Alain Vaillant parle même d’unité anthropologique essentielle.
C’est un invariant à travers toutes les cultures au même titre que les structures de parenté,
la religion, le langage ou l’attrait pour le beurre salé.
Ah non ça, c'est juste pour les Bretons.
On trouve même des clowns tribaux.
C’est des personnages burlesques, le plus souvent des hommes,
qui transgressent les règles pour amuser la galerie.
Ils imitent les danseurs en dansant comme un pied et à contretemps,
ils interrompent bruyamment les incantations religieuses en parlant à tort et à travers.
En gros, ils font des pitreries qui font mourir de rire tout le monde.
Souvent, on leur attribue même des pouvoirs de guérison, un peu comme les chamans.
Ce rire, qui est universel chez l’humain, à quoi il peut bien nous servir ?
Déjà, il faut savoir que c’est une forme de communication qui apparaît bien avant la parole.
On émet notre premier éclat de rire quand on a entre 4 et 6 mois,
et qu’on réalise enfin l’absurdité de la vie,
qu’on apprend qu’on va devoir trimer comme des bêtes pour ne pas toucher de retraite et que de toutes façons on va mourir seuls.
Ou alors juste quand on se fait chatouiller ou qu’on joue à des jeux comme “coucou qui c’est ?”
Des chercheurs se sont aperçus que des enfants nés sourds et aveugles arrivent à rire spontanément sans même avoir pu l’apprendre de leur entourage.
Et ça, ça laisse à penser que le rire serait un réflexe
c’est-à-dire une réponse involontaire, très rapide et stéréotypée à un stimulus
un réflexe donc, inné chez l’Homme.
Et pas que chez l’Homme d’ailleurs !
Chez la femme aussi !
Certains animaux se bidonnent aussi.
Regardez.
Ce bon vieux Darwin s’était déjà penché sur nos cousins poilus.
Je ne parle pas de ma cousine Shirley.
Darwin donc, qui décrivait le rire comme “l’expression primitive de la joie”,
a identifié un comportement similaire chez… les singes.
Macaques, babouins, chimpanzées,
bonobos, orangs-outans, gorilles,...
Tous affichent une expression caractéristique quand ils jouent ou quand ils se chatouillent,
c’est la play face.
Un visage détendu, bouche ouverte, couvrant leurs dents avec leurs lèvres.
Certains comme les chimpanzés émettent aussi des vocalisations qui ressemblent à notre rire, une sorte de halètement.
Vous aurez remarqué que contrairement à nous, ils émettent un son en inspirant et en expirant, un peu comme ça
Mais alors, pourquoi le nôtre est si différent de celui des autres primates ?*
Apparemment, il s’est passé un truc quelque part après que notre branche ait divergé de celle des chimpanzés et des bonobos, environ 6 millions d’années avant ma mère.
Mais quel truc ?
Eh bah on sait pas. Peut-être qu'il n'y a rien eu du tout.
Notre rire aurait juste été pimpé par hasard et conservé au cours de l’évolution. C’est fort probable.
Mais pour certains chercheurs, l’apparition de notre rire si particulier aurait pu être favorisé par...
la bipédie.
Vous savez, ce moment où on s’est dit que ça coûterait moins cher en chaussures de marcher sur deux pattes et qu’on tiendrait mieux dans le métro comme ça.
C’est la “Bipedal Theory”.
Pour la comprendre, il faut d’abord s’intéresser à la version 4 pattes pour la comparer à la version 2 pattes.
C’est une histoire de biomécanique.
Les chercheurs se sont rendu compte que les mammifères quadrupèdes ont une respiration calée sur leur démarche.
Ce pattern serait directement lié au fait qu’ils se déplacent à quatre pattes.
Comme le thorax est comprimé à chaque fois qu’ils posent le pied par terre, ils ne peuvent respirer qu’entre chaque pas.
Ça les contraindrait donc à caler une respiration par enjambée.
Grâce à la bipédie, l’humain se serait affranchi de ces contraintes de compression du thorax,
ce qui nous aurait permis d’allonger considérablement nos respirations.
Mais ça nous aurait permis de développer par la même occasion des petites fantaisies comme le rire et, plus tard, le langage.
Ce qui me permet aujourd’hui de vous raconter tout ça. La nature est bien faite.
En 2009, des chercheurs américains et allemands sont même allés plus loin.
Ils ont tenté de deviner comment riait l’ancêtre commun à tous les primates.
Pour ça, ils ont chatouillé des bébés humains ainsi que 21 bébés orangs-outans, gorilles, chimpanzés et bonobos. Ca devait être adorable.
Puis ils ont accroché ces différents enregistrements de rigolades sur les branches de l’arbre du vivant.
Ils ont arrosé le tout copieusement avec des analyses phylogénétiques,
Et ils ont déraciné l’arbre pour retrouver notre ancêtre commun, qui vivait 10 à 16 millions d’années avant Justin Bieber.
Et qui, en définitive, se poilait probablement comme nos cousins poilus. Encore une fois, pas Shirley.
Au final, le rire du papi de tous les primates ressemblait probablement à des courtes séries de cris formé d’expirations successives
et très sales, avec plein de fréquences dedans, comme ce qu’on a entendu chez le chimpanzé.
Donc déjà, ce qu’on peut dire à ce niveau de l’histoire, c’est que le rire n’est pas du tout le propre de l’Homme. Non au spécisme.
Mais c'est pas fini.
Si vous croyez que les primates sont les seuls à se poiler, écoutez un peu ça.
Il y a 20 ans, le neuroscientifique estonien Jaak Panksepp s’est amusé à chatouiller des rats de laboratoire…
Panksepp s’est donc aperçu qu’un rat chatouillé gazouille aux alentours de 50kHz, dans les ultrasons.
Des sons que notre oreille n’entend pas, et que le scientifique a découvert grâce à un appareil pour écouter les chauve-souris à la base.
Il a constaté les mêmes pépiements ultrasoniques quand les bébés rats jouent entre eux, ou quand les adultes s’accouplent.
Pour Panskepp, ces cris s’apparentent à un rire.
Sa conclusion a laissé perplexe une bonne partie de la communauté scientifique,
mais lui, il en est convaincu.
Ce pépiement ultrasonique est associé à une émotion positive.
Et les rats sont plus optimistes et de meilleure humeur après avoir gazouillé. (Et oui, il y a des expériences pour mesurer l’optimisme d’un rat).
Depuis, des chercheurs militent même pour qu’on chatouille les rats de laboratoire pour augmenter leur bien-être. On leur doit bien ça, après tout.
Mais les rats sont pas les seuls mammifères sociaux à se payer une tranche de rigolade.
Des études ont conclu positivement pour le grand dauphin (vous savez, notre pote Flipper) et le chien.
Alors pour le dauphin, il s’agirait d’une série de pulsations brèves suivies d’un sifflement, qu’ils émettent quand ils se chamaillent.
Les chercheurs pensent qu’ils émettraient ce son pour signaler à leurs camarades qu’ils ne font que jouer à la bagarre, que c’est pour de faux.
Et c’est justement l’une des hypothèses évolutives sur le rôle du rire.
D’après cette théorie, la fonction primaire du rire aurait été de dire à ses petits copains.
«Vous avez entendu ce bruit-là ?
Ah nan c'est bon, j'ai vérifié, y a pas de danger.
Pour d’autres chercheurs, le rire serait un moyen de répandre rapidement la bonne humeur autour de soi.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la théorie de la contagion émotionnelle.
Ce qui permettrait de bien disposer son interlocuteur afin qu’il coopère avec nous.
C’est d’ailleurs une des fonctions évolutives qu’on donne à l’humour.
Tu fais rigoler les gens autour de toi dans l’espoir qu’ils viennent t’aider dans le futur, quand t’auras besoin d’un coup de main.
Du coup, le rire, c'est forcément utilisé dans la pub, non ?
Oui, le rire, c'est la notion qui fait le plus vendre en fait.
En fait, tu vois, une pub, ça sert à quoi ? Il y a plusieurs objectifs, il faut capter l'attention.
Il faut convaincre la personne qui la voit.
Il faut ensuite qu'elle mémorise la marque et ce genre de choses. Et le rire, ça peut vraiment servir à toutes ces parties là.
Dans tous les cas, l'affect va toujours plus marquer que l'intellect.
C'est pour ça d'ailleurs que tu as beaucoup plus de publicités qui vont jouer sur le fait de générer des émotions que
de commencer à juste lister ce produit sert à ça, à ça, à ça, juste des arguments de vente de manière hyper austères.
Ça c'est un premier point. Après, jouer l'émotion, oui, tu peux jouer sur plein d'émotions.
Mais tout ce qui est émotion négative, c'est associé des émotions négatives à une marque et c'est toujours un peu risqué.
Chose que les gens du marketing n'aime pas trop.
Donc, on préfère aller sur des trucs assez safe, faire de l'humour, faire du rire.
De un, tu as un côté où tout le monde aime rire, ça détend, ça capte naturellement, ça crée de la sympathie.
Et ça va créer cette forme de relation avec le spectateur qui tombe devant la publicité.
Il va vraiment créer un rapport entre les deux.
Par cette interaction, il baisse un peu sa garde,
la publicité me fait marrer alors je suis un peu moins attentif à tous les autres aspects plus rationnels.
Après, le rire, ça ne marche pas dans tous les cas. Suivant différents produits, tu n'as pas les mêmes applications.
Si tu achètes une voiture ou si tu achètes un soda, c'est pas vraiment le même niveau. Il y en a un, tu dois beaucoup plus réfléchir et te poser.
En gros, plus le produit demande de l'investissement, de la réflexion, de rationaliser le truc,
plus mettre du rire dans la communication est risquée.
Même si en vrai ça se fait, c'est juste que c'est plus risqué et ça doit se faire de manière plus dosé.
Donc, tu fais rigoler pour vendre du soda, mais pas une voiture ?
Alors tu peux, tu peux autant ne pas faire rigoler pour du soda, et tu peux faire rigoler pour une voiture. C'est jusque que c'est plus dangereux, plus risqué.
Il faut faire attention et voir comment le faire. C'est très dur de faire des publicités humoristiques dans le cadre de truc sérieux, type assurances, ce genre de choses.
Après, il y a une expérience qui a été faite où justement on a testé suivant le type d'humour, la cible et le produit, c'est plein de facteurs qui font que ça influence vraiment l'efficacité d'une publicité.
On a remarqué par exemple que l'humour absurde, c'était mieux pour la persuasion, l'humour sexuel, un peu beauf, ça marchait mieux pour la mémorisation.
Mais à l'inverse, ce qui pouvait tuer la mémorisation, c'était de l'humour un peu provocant.
Donc on peut dire que le rire est très utilisé en publicité, ça a été démontré qu'il a vraiment de vrais effets
sur le cerveau, en termes de mémorisation,
et même de sympathie et d'engagement envers une marque.
Et c'est bon pour capter l'attention, si on voit un truc dynamique qui se passe, on va beaucoup plus accroché.
Parce qu'on est intrigué au début, on voit qu'il va y avoir une chute, un truc marrant, plutôt que de lister les arguments.
Ce qu'il vient de dire, ça me fait penser à l'aspect contagieux du rire.
Difficile de rester de marbre quand on entend des rires. Et c’est un truc que les producteurs de sitcoms ont un peu trop bien compris.
Un peu trop bien compris même.
Tiens, ça me fait penser, en Tanzanie, dans les années 60 à peu près,
Il y a une école qui avait pris un fou rire de malade, parce que des gamins avaient transmis leur fou rire à leurs parents,
qui l'ont transmis aux villages alentours.
Ce qui fait qu'à la fin, il y avait à peu près 1000 personnes qui avaient un fou rire incontrôlable et ça a duré environ 1 an et demi.
Mais c'est horrible cette histoire.
Non, c'est super drôle, je trouve.
Mais c'est un cas d'hystérie collective en fait ?
Je sais pas, en tout cas, j'aurais bien voulu connaître la blague de base.
- Oui, on sait pas ça ?
- Non.
Oh c'est con.
Les scientifiques soupçonnent que le rire fonctionnerait un peu comme le bâillement, par un réseau de neurones miroir.
Mais surtout, la caractéristique principale du rire, c’est qu’il est social !
Le philosophe Henri Bergson avait déjà souligné cette dimension.
En 1900, il écrivait : « Le rire a besoin d’un écho
Écoutez-le bien, ce n’est pas un son articulé, net, terminé,
c’est quelque chose qui voudrait se prolonger en se répercutant de proche en proche,
quelque chose qui commence par un éclat pour se continuer par des roulements, ainsi que le tonnerre dans la montagne.»
C’est vachement émouvant et tellement juste.
Bon, ok, il a aussi écrit dans le même livre qu’on “riait des nègres” parce que notre imagination les voyait comme des blancs “mal lavés”,
au visage “barbouillé d’encre ou de suie”... coup dur pour Bergson.
Même si bon, l’époque, le contexte, toussa…
Donc, le rire est social. En réalité, on a 30 fois plus de chances de s’esclaffer quand on est avec des gens plutôt que quand on est tout seul.
Et là, je vous vois venir : mais pfeu, tu dis n’importe quoi, je rigole tout le temps tout seul.
Ce à quoi, je vous répondrai : vous êtes sûrs que vous n’étiez pas à ce moment-là en train de repenser à une conversation que vous auriez eue plus tôt,
en train de lire un livre ou de regarder une vidéo hilarante comme celle-ci ?
Donc que vous étiez pas vraiment seuls, au final.
Et si vous me dites que non, vraiment ; là je vous dirai 1.
autant pour moi, 2. que c’est un peu triste quelque part de rire tout seul,
et 3. que ça m’arrive souvent aussi, du coup que 4. je confirme que c’est un peu triste, et surtout 5. j’ai pas vraiment d’explication scientifique
mais j’en ai une quand-même parce que j’ai réponse à tout.
Et c’est ce débonnaire de Charles Baudelaire qui nous la donne.
En fait, d’après lui, quand on s’esclaffe tout seul, on rit de se voir rire.
C’est parce qu’en fait, on se dédouble et une part de nous se réjouit du rire de l’autre part. À méditer.
Bref, cet aspect social du rire est aussi valable chez les autres primates ! Parce que les singes aussi s’esclaffent principalement quand ils sont avec leurs compères,
et rarement tout seul.
Les chercheurs pensent que le rire (et avec lui, l’humour) serait un lubrifiant social.
Rigolez pas, c’est très sérieux.
En gros, il servirait à consolider les liens sociaux et affectifs.
Certains d’entre eux considèrent même le rire et l’humour comme une “caresse par procuration”,
puisqu’une bonne marrade procurerait le même plaisir qu’un contact physique.
On ne précise pas quel type de contact.
Mais ce qui est marrant, c’est que la plupart du temps, le rire n’est pas du tout associé à l’humour !
En l’an 2000, alors qu’on élisait la première femme présidente de Finlande, que la station spatiale internationale accueillait ses tout premiers occupants,
et que la reine d’Angleterre soufflait ses 210 bougies, le chercheur américain Robert Provine, lui, écoutait les conversations des gens dans la rue.
Il a analysé au total 1200 épisodes de grosse rigolade.
Résultat : moins d’un rire sur 5 répondait à un trait d’humour.
La plupart du temps, c’était plutôt pour ponctuer des répliques banales comme “regarde, c’est Jean-Michel”, “t’es sûr ?” ou “c’était chouette de te rencontrer.”
Ce serait avant tout pour créer du lien avec son interlocuteur, du coup.
L’humour en particulier fait appel au rire Duchenne, le vrai, l'authentique, toujours imité jamais égalé.
Mais dans une conversation, 8 à 9 rires sur 10 seraient fake, ce serait des rires non Duchenne.
On pense que ce rire-là serait apparu plus tard au cours de l’évolution, par détournement du rire “vrai”.
Ce qui nous amène justement au… côté obscur du rire.
Tin tin tin !
Et ce qui me permet d’écouler à nouveau du Bergson, histoire de rentabiliser le temps que j’ai passé à scroller les images de citations inspirantes.
Le rire, dit-il, “peut cheminer à l’intérieur d’un cercle aussi large qu’on voudra,
le cercle n’en reste pas moins fermé. Notre rire est toujours le rire d’un groupe.
Un homme, à qui l’on demandait pourquoi il ne pleurait pas à un sermon où tout le monde versait des larmes, répondit :
«Je ne suis pas de la paroisse. »
Ce que cet homme pensait des larmes serait bien plus vrai du rire.”
Et c’est là qu’est tout le drame. Le rire rapproche, mais il exclut aussi.
Là, on parle toujours uniquement du rire non Duchenne, le "non spontané".
Ce qu’on appelle le "côté noir du rire", donc, est lié notamment à la théorie de la supériorité, défendue par quelques philosophes comme Aristote, Platon,
et, devinez, je vous le donne en mille, exactement, oui c’est lui, Bergson !
Il disait d’ailleurs : “Le rire a pour fonction…
Nan mais y en a marre, y en a marre, on n'en peut plus de Bergson là.
C'est fini. Ok. Il nous saoule.
- Il nous saoule.
- Mais il parle bien.
Donc. Selon cette théorie, rigoler permettrait de se sentir supérieur à son interlocuteur.
C'est typiquement ce qui se passe quand on se moque de quelqu'un, on le rabaisse, on le tourne en ridicule.
C'est la différence entre "rire avec" et "rire de" quelqu'un.
C’est aussi le rire qu'on utilise pour ponctuer une phrase blessante et faire passer la pilule alors qu'en fait on rigole pas du tout.
Vous voyez très bien ce à quoi je fais allusion. Personne n’est dupe.
- Ah j'ai une citation pour ça.
- OH NAN !
Si, c'est pas Bergson ce coup-là, c'est Hobbes.
La passion du rire n'est rien d'autre qu'une gloire soudaine,
et dans ce sentiment de gloire, il est toujours question de se glorifier par rapport à autrui,
de sorte que lorsqu'on rit de vous, on se moque de vous, on triomphe de vous et on vous méprise.
Il aimait pas trop rigoler.
Et sans aller jusqu'à la moquerie, le simple fait de ne pas comprendre une blague peut engendrer un sentiment d'exclusion.
C'est d'ailleurs la fonction ultime du rire et de l'humour telle que proposée par Richard Alexander en 1986.
Pour lui, l'humour s'est développé initialement en tant qu'outil social qui facilite l'exclusion et la formation de coalitions.
Ceux qui rient ensemble se rapprochent et ostracisent les autres. C’est mal, d’ostraciser autrui.
C’est en tout cas un moyen de manipuler son statut social, en s'élevant soi-même (et ses complices) et en rabaissant les autres.
Ça, c’est la théorie de la manipulation sociale.
Il y a aussi le cas très particulier de l'autodérision. Quand on se moque de soi-même, on se rabaisse, c'est un peu contre-intuitif.
Pourquoi on fait ça ?
D'après Alexander, y a des points positifs à cette affaire.
Ca permettrait à la fois d’élever le statut de l’auditeur pour améliorer notre relation avec lui,
de montrer qu’on est tellement haut dans la hiérarchie sociale que de toutes façons, on peut se permettre de blaguer sur nous, on craint rien.
Et puis y’a aussi ce que j’ai baptisé à l’instant-même l’effet “même pas mal”.
Si quelqu’un se moque de nous et qu’on rigole avec lui, on désamorce l’effet de la blague.
On montre ostensiblement qu’elle ne nous porte pas préjudice. Même pas mal.
Inversement, quand on fait exprès de ne pas rire à la blague de quelqu'un, ça permet de rabaisser le statut de cette personne et de montrer que nous, on vaut mieux que ça.
Et c’est là tout le pouvoir du rire non Duchenne.
Après, cette théorie de la manipulation sociale a ses limites.
Principalement, son auteur s'est focalisé sur les blagues comportant un souffre-douleur alors que l'humour est loin de se résumer à ça.
Mais bon, ça donne des pistes de réflexion.
Récapitulons. Une épidémie de fou-rire a paralysé un bout de la Tanzanie pendant un an et demi,
l’ancêtre commun des primates rigolait comme un asthmatique,
Bergson a dit plein de choses et tout le monde s’en fout à part moi,
les rats gazouillent quand ils sont heureux,
on rigole rarement parce que c’est drôle mais surtout pour créer du lien et caresser virtuellement nos proches,
mais on peut aussi s’en servir pour rabaisser les gens.
En tout cas, aujourd’hui, on sait pas vraiment définitivement pour sûr pourquoi on rigole.
On se dit que c’est un signal de communication, bien antérieur à la parole. Mais pour dire quoi ?
Étrangement, c’est un sujet assez peu étudié.
Peut-être parce qu’il a pas l’air assez sérieux.
C’est dommage parce que c’est un sujet qui nous touche absolument tous.
Enfin, sauf Monté.
Et comme disait Bergson, “Table des matières”.
Je vous l’accorde, c’est pas sa meilleure.
Merci abonne-toi, si tu aimes les caresses par procuration,
like cette vidéo et n’hésite pas à la partager pour toujours plus de bashing des Bretons.
Et retrouve-nous sur le Discord pour discuter du beurre demi-sel.
Du coup, j'ai pas compris si j'ai perdu ou pas moi.
Bah moi, j'ai carrément pas compris le but du jeu.
J'ai l'impression que le goal du truc, c'était un peu d'oter le malaise en riant un bon coup, mais j'ai l'impression qu'on a plutôt créer le malaise en fait.
Bah littéralement.
Attend, comment ça, littéralement ?
Derrière toi, Shirley là.
La cousine de Valentine.
Bah quoi ?
Elle a tellement ri qu'elle a fait un malaise.
Ah merde, c'est pas grave j'espère ?
Bah je sais pas, réveille-la pour voir, tu verras bien.
Nan mais là, on a un problème hein.
Ça vous a plus, vous en voulez encore ?
Alors rejoignez-moi, maintenant, tout de suite, sur Twitch,
où je suis pendant que cette vidéo est mise en ligne
et comme ça, on va pouvoir débriefer tout ça ensemble.
Et j'ai même des contenus exclusifs à vous montrer, des petits trucs que j'ai glané au fil de mes recherches.
Et venez, ça va être ludique.